[Music]
hey guys it's justine and today we have
in front of me the brand new lego mario
set i already have this all built out
for a level that i created using three
different expansion sets plus the
starter kit back here this is the
starter course you have to have the
starter course or the rest of the things
won't work with it it all works together
i'll show you that in a second the
piranha plant expansion
we have the boomer bill barrage
expansion set and then this big boy this
is toad's treasure hunt and i got one of
the power up packs so this is the cat
suit mario and when you use the power
suit packs these are really cool because
they can give mario different attributes
this entire ecosystem connects with an
app now when you open this up for the
first time there's nothing here at all
so you have to go in here and this is
where you'll add your sets so for
example i've already added these sets a
little dialog will pop up and it'll make
you scan one of the pieces of the sets
with your mario so that it'll know that
that's the set that you want to use then
the set will appear here it'll give you
all of the building directions and you
can get started to build your lego
creations they also give you these
little instructional videos inside of
the directions so that'll give you some
further inspiration to create the
courses all your own there's so many
different things that you can do inside
of this app but i'm going to show you
just the basics and we're going to run
through this course that i created so
first steps first we need to connect
mario so let's turn him on
he has
a little lcd at the bottom you'll see
there's this little light here so it's
actually a color scanner it will be able
to determine what color bricks that
mario is placed on and a lot of these
bricks also have these little color
scanners so our little baby bowser here
you can see has one of the codes on his
shell so when i touch mario to it
he'll then interact with whatever item
he is being placed on top of and as we
place him on the red
that's fire we can get a little goomba
you can get coins
so the starter course comes with the
start and the end pieces so you need the
start and the end to complete oh sorry
to complete a course if you shake him
around he starts making noises this is
probably one of my favorite interactive
elements this is a little cloud so you
put mario on top of the cloud
and this will allow you to
move mario around from place to place
so that you can get some coins this
plays a big part inside of my course
because i have two separate courses here
one here and one here but the cloud is
how i'm able to connect them all
together ready mario
mario was all connected and one of the
cool things is after you run this course
when mario is connected to your phone he
will give you the option to save your
score and you can take a picture of your
level of your masterpiece to share with
others
and if they want to recreate it they can
so mario
let's do this
[Music]
gotta be very careful because mario can
fall off and he'll get stunned
[Music]
hello got that extra time boost
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
i got 88 coins
so this syncs up to your phone and it
shows you all of the stuff that you hit
all the coins that you received from
every single item this is where it gets
cool because you can add a title
we're gonna call this
fun town
now we take a picture of it so there it
is you can click save and then other
people can see your works of art and
enjoy your lego creations what's so fun
about this is like i was really
letting this kind of be up to your
imagination they're giving you kind of
the starting processes how to put things
together but then you can just get crazy
they make them so that you can just
unsnap them and each little piece is
kind of modular so each one of these can
be moved around you can put it wherever
you want if i decide that i want this to
be over here you can easily make
whatever you want but i'm gonna put this
back here because i spent a lot of time
making this and
i like my course
so now i'm gonna show you guys the
powerup suit we're gonna put on the cat
suit to mario but first i'm gonna try to
have mario walk on the wall
doesn't happen but now we're gonna put
the cat suit on
sorry mario i gotta take your overalls
off
so let's take mario for a ride
over to the wall ready mario
[Music]
so i'm now getting coins on the wall and
he's making little meow sounds
[Music]
this was so much fun to put together i
think this is a collaboration nintendo
and lego that we have all been waiting
for well some of us i think
maybe most of our lives i'm excited and
i can't wait to get some of the other
sets i'll put a link in the description
where you guys can check out more
information about all of these sets on
lego's website and in the meantime
i don't know i need to work on a new
masterpiece
[Music]